الياس بدايه بالحصي الثقيله خلال 24 ساعه
14 ضابطا وجنديا ووقعها سواء من حيث الكم
ام النوع ايضا هذا يحمل مؤشرات فيما يتعلق
بسير المعارك
البريه بالفعل مياده وواضح بان هذا يوم
مؤلم لاسرائيل وهم يعبرون عن ذلك كيوم
حداد على اعتبار ان القتلى والجرحى هم
باعداد كبيره في هذه ال المعارك وهذا دليل
على حجم ال التوغل الاسرائيلي على حجم
المعارك الضاريه وشراستها وعلى جاهزيه
المقاومه ال الفلسطينيه في التصدي لهذا
الهجوم الاسرائيلي البري في اكثر من محور
واكثر من مكان من الواضح بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه قد اعدت العده جيدا لمثل هذه
العمليه البريه على اعتبار اننا ما زلنا
اي نشهد عمليات عسكريه وقدره فائقه لدى
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في مواجهه الجيش
الاسرائيلي في كل المواقع في كل مواقع
الاشتباك وليس فقط في المناطق الجنوبيه
حيث تقول اسرائيل بانها تركز الان قواتها
وعملياتها البريه هنا في المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه المعارك على اشدها وهو وهي
ضاريه وشرسه للغايه حتى في المناطق
القريبه من السياج الامني مياده في منطقه
بيت حنون في بيت لاهيا القصف المدفعي لا
يتوقف الرشاشات الثقيله تعمل وهي مؤشر على
اشتباكات مسلحه تجري على الارض في اكثر من
مكان هناك وكذلك هنا في جباليا جباليا
اليوم شهدت معركه حقيقيه بكل ما تحمله
الكلمه من معنى وكنا شهودا عليها في
الساعات الاخيره حيث اشتد القصف المدفعي
والجوي وكانت هنالك المروحيات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه من نوع اباتشي التي كانت تحوم
في اجواء المنطقه وتقصف بالصواريخ وتطلق
زخات من الرشاشات من العيار الثقيل على
اكثر من موقع وعلى اكثر من مكان وايضا
كانت هنالك عمليه نقل لجنود جرحى من ميدان
المعركه حيث كانت مروحيه اسرائيليه قد
قدمت الى منطقه غلاف غزه في الساعه
الاخيره ونقلت كما يبدو عددا من الجنود
الجرحى وعندما تشتغل وحده الانقاذ 669 في
نقل الجنود هذا يكون مؤشر على ان الجرحى
في صفوف الجنود الاسرائيليين توصف بان
جراحهم خطيره للغايه لذلك هم ينقلون على
عجل من خلال وحده الانقاذ هذه الى
المستشفيات الاسرائيليه سواء كان ذلك في
عسقلان او اسدود او في بئر السبع في
مستشفى سوروكا المعارك على اشدها والجيش
الاسرائيلي يعترف بان هنالك معارك ضاريه
حتى في بياناته العسكريه ويلمح الى ان
الانفاق الهجوميه باتت تقد مضاجع الجيش
الاسرائيلي حقيقه على اعتبار ان اسرائيل
لا يمكنها ان تصل او ان تعرف استخباراتيه
عن اماكن وجود هذه الانفاق وتشعباتها
وامتداداتها وبالتالي هي تشكل ربما الخطر
الاكبر الان على القوات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة
مقربه من الغوص في وحل غزه كما يقولون او
على مقربه
لخوض معارك استنزاف مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ذلك انه لا يوجد حسم عسكري في
الميدان والغلبه واليد الطوله هي للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه التي تعرف بخبايا هذه المناطق
وبالا ازقه وبكل ما اعددته من كمائن بينما
الجيش الاسرائيلي يبدو عاجزا في مواجهه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في حرب الاستنزاف هذه
التي تدور رحاها في اكثر ا من موقع وفي
اكثر من مكان م طيب الياس فيما يخص
التكتيكات كيف يبدو الوضع خاصه اننا قبل
يومين كنا نتحدث عن انسحاب وحده جولاني
وهي من وحدات النخبه وقبلها بايام كنا نرى
دعما لوجستيا عبر جسر جوي للمناطق الواقعه
في شمال قطاع غزه كيف تبدو تكتيكات الجيش
الاسرائيلي في هذه
المرحله ميا لا ادري عن اي تكتيكات تتحدث
ونحن نواجه هنا في المنطقه الشماليه لقطاع
غزه معارك ضاريه وكانها يعني في اليوم
الاول للاجتياح البري الاسرائيلي الجيش
الاسرائيلي يواجه مشكله عويصه حقيقه هو
ادخل كل الياته العسكريه وكل جنوده وكل
دباباته ووحداته الخاصه يحاول ان يصل الى
معاقل حركه حماس يصل احيانا يدمر
المستودعات لكن مشكلته الاساسيه تكمن في
ما هو تحت الارض ما هو في باطن الارض
فتوحات الانف فاق والانفاق الهجوميه مياده
كنا نشير الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي كان
يتباهى او تباهى بعد ايار عام 20211 بانه
تمكن من تدمير ما يعرف بمترو الانفاق عبر
غارات جويه متتاليه كنا شهودا عليها في
احدى ليالي الحرب تلك عندما كانت اكثر من
100 طائره مقاتله اسرائيليه تحوم في اجواء
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه وتضرب كل ما
كان لديها من قنابل وقنابل خارقه
للتحصينات المناطق الشماليه حيث كان يعتقد
بانها شبكه الانفاق الهجوميه التابعه
لحركه حماس واسرائيل تباهت بانها دمرتها
وقدت عليها لكن من الواضح بان اسرائيل لم
تتمكن من تدمير هذه المنظومه تحت الارضيه
التابعه لحركه حماس وهي منظومه استراتيجيه
هي التي تكبد الان الجيش الاسرائيلي
الخسائر الفادحه بالارواح و بالعتاد وهذا
يقودنا مياده الى ما يقوله ايضا الخبراء
العسكريون والقيادات العسكريه والامنيه في
اسرائيل بانه يعني خذي على سبيل المثال ما
يقوله يوسي كوهن وهو كان رئيس المساد
السابق في اسرائيل يقول بانه لن نتمكن من
القضاء على الفكر العقائدي لحركه حماس
يقول نوعم تيفون وهو قائد فيلق الشمال
بالجيش الاسرائيلي سابقا يقول انه يجب ان
نقول الصدق للاسرائيليين انه حركه حماس ما
زالت قادره على السيطره والتحكم ونحن
بعيدون عن تقويضها يعني هنالك حاله حتى من
الياس وفقدان الامل في اوساط سياسيين وعس
ريين سابقين وفي اوساط ايضا كتاب الاعمده
في اسرائيل الذين يقولون بانه يجب ربما
تغيير اهداف اهداف هذه الحرب لان اسرائيل
والحكومه الاسرائيليه ربما وضعت اهدافا
غير واقعيه غير قابله للتحقيق ويجب الان
تغييرها لانه لا يمكن القضاء على حركه
حماس كما يبدو لا عسكريا ولا سلطويا
والاهم من ذلك هو ما قاله ايضا رئيس
المساد في هذا السياق يوس كوهن وما ذكرته
قبل قليل انه نعمم القضاء عقائديا على
حركه حماس وعلى هذا الفكر الذي تحمله في
المقاومه وفي الدعوه لتحرير الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه
وتقرير المصير نشكرك حتى اللحظه من غلاف
غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام